this is one of the 20 boxing gyms in
bucum it's austere it's crowded with
ambitious young men wanting to follow in
the footsteps of their heroes 17-year
old Philip trained here every day for
the last six years like many boys and
girls in the community he dropped out of
school to focus on boxing
every day of the year we wake up and go
to the gym and farts and some people see
me as a potential world champion his
parents want you to stay in school but
says right now is focused on his
ambition his coach says boxing offers a
life to young men like Philip otherwise
would be out on the streets and there
are hundreds in the fishing community
nearly everyone here in Bochum is either
boxer or loves the game it's a tough
neighborhood where opportunities are
limited yet despite that this area has
produced some of Africa's best boxers a
short distance away for a diesel a man
sets her eye on a continental
championship growing up she had two
dreams to join the army and be a good
boxer she believes doing well and the
competition will help I achieve our
second ambition but she is not happy
with the lack of opportunity for girls
in the sport there's no notes being made
also that I will bring a lot of medals
to Ghana let's see where we come to
training you know motivators for it is
confident of reaching our goals of
becoming a professional boxer but in
Bochum not many young women and girls
can say that
Phillip on the other hand has a lot of
ground to cover as competition here is
stiff and there is little help coming
his way
but says he's determined to give his
best to get there how many trees
al-jazeera bucum ghana